all right
what is she doing Chris what's up man
finally good to meet you
so I'm having the Dilemma right
so we all go through phases in our life
we spin plates we have a couple of a
couple of Honeys on rotation but we tend
to gravitate towards one whether or not
they know it or not right
the more we kind of get closer to a girl
the more she pushes away so we kind of
have to keep her at Bay in order to for
her to keep chasing her validation right
well the crappy part is I've known this
girl for just over about a month and a
half all right and she's a Colombian
woman so just to give you a little
background
surgery dude that's the thing and The
Story Goes I met her as is Perfectly
Natural she has a couple of tattoos that
I find kind of whatever but you meet
somebody as the first time you see them
you don't really think much of it right
well
she would go back and forth to Columbia
often you know see some family but she
says over the New Year I'm going down to
Colombia you're gonna have to say for
three weeks I say well what the hell for
she tells me and she tells me basically
while she's drunk you know I had a New
Year's party with her family down in
Miami that she's going to have her tits
done so I'm like Jesus Christ man at
least let me enjoy them for a few months
time you know before you go up and get
them chopped up okay so I'm thinking
this girl you know I hold frame as a
gentleman before you tell was talking
about the girl is great about 80 of the
time you know we're you're not going to
get 100 out of a woman right if you can
get 75 to 80 of her being on your term I
find that a win right especially for a
potential LTR
so I'm 32. okay thank you sir and she's
29 and she's a cool chick right but I
don't normally get too invested in women
because like I said The more investment
you show the more they pull away so you
kind of have to play that game right
yeah so she goes down to Colombia this
past last week and I believe we had
spent a weekend together in Savannah
Georgia I'm in Northeast Florida
everything was great and I'm thinking
you know the entire time I can kind of I
didn't make an admission to co-works or
out of it but she kept bringing it up to
me about how she's going going and I
said every time we you know having fun
together I'm like you don't need to cut
any of this this is perfect but not to
the point where it was iffy you know you
say your point you leave it alone
well needless to say she went ahead and
did it this last week and Thursday I
didn't hear from her she left Monday
I I gave her about two days you know
alone time
and then Thursday I hit her up just to
be you know courteous I said I think
you're certain you told me your surgery
is today hope everything goes to plan
hopefully you're happy but more
importantly healthy let me know when you
recover hit me up when you recover
so she hits me up about you know nine
ten hours later basically tell me how
she's in the hospital still she's
spending the night going home thank you
so much for your wishes blah blah blah I
can't get over this [__] man I'm like
supremely [__] annoyed because I like
what I love you
I like what I like and I am into more
natural but it's more so what what I
find that tends to piss me off
is that the timing sucks because it's
only been a month so you know my body my
choice they can do whatever the hell
they want you don't have that it's not
your girlfriend she's a girl that you're
dating exactly so I understand that it's
a good time frame basically for them to
say well [__] it I'm gonna do what I
wanted she said that but at the same
time it kind of frustrates me because in
the past whether I've known a girl for a
year you've known her and I wasn't as
strong as I was now in terms of dealing
with women of course as we age or get
better
but whether it's a year or two weeks or
two months it's kind of like I get
pissed off that they don't take my my
opinion they don't value my opinion in
terms of what I would like from them in
terms of something that's more of a
self-conscious precision well Chris
let's be honest I mean you know you've
known her for a month if it was exactly
a year five years and she was going
against your wishes then I would say
okay we have a conversation that we kind
of need to have sort of thing on that of
course but women today they don't
typically follow the guidance that men
set they don't like when men set
boundaries for them healthy boundaries
like you know don't hang out with men
they don't like what their parents
right so you know they're not going to
like hearing it from a guy because
they've been told for you know their
entire lifetime you don't need no man
you know correct men and women are equal
blah blah blah
did did she have a small cup was it an A
cup or something or like what no no she
was virgin on on these on a simple D
like they were perfect she complained
that she wants a lift right but you know
what that means when you go down to
South America their ideology of what's
beautiful is not what a doctor in Miami
or Beverly Hills is going to do he ain't
gonna make them look natural and and
nice it's going to make them look like
[__] bolt-ons because
she showed me the Instagram of the
doctor my God man everyone looked like a
copy paste [__] Barbie doll and the
thing is she's not the most fit to where
she doesn't have a flat toned stomach
right she's got a little fluffy belly
which is beautiful to me but you go put
on bolt-ons then nothing else matches
just wait for more surgery you know what
I mean yeah okay and and that's you see
the fact that I'm calling in to discuss
this with you is almost like pissing me
off the fact that I have to get it off
my chest right because normally I would
let them you know do whatever the [__]
you want but of course as a man deep
down you're like this is good LTR
material but [__] me I can't do anything
about it and what if I don't like it
when I see him good that's the problem
um brother and uh listen I'm good with
either okay like I don't I don't
discriminate as am I if I met her that
way I'd love them okay absolutely so
talk to me look I mean as far as LTR
material like if you're if you're
spinning plates and you're dating this
gal and you got a few other things on
the go and you know you've you've
expressed that it's not your preference
and she goes and does it anyway yeah
then you know it's just you know what it
is no like I dig your Vibe like you know
we'll see how this oh look oh Becky's
over here let's talk to her tonight sort
of thing you know what it is yeah so
like that's just the way that you have
to handle it right like you have to like
you don't hate that that's gonna have to
yeah but that's that that's the game
that you kind of have to play today
unfortunately right I mean you've
already expressed you know what your
preference was you already expressed
that you liked her the way that she was
she wasn't happy with herself she did it
anyway yeah check it out when she gets
back you know see see if you dig her
vibe still you know see if you like the
new bolt-ons you know as you call them
you know the tailor-mades
yeah if I don't just just give me your
opinion if the scarring is too much
because a lot of it is attraction we
know that it's all yeah a problem yeah
well they have they have ways of getting
them in there without much scarring now
so I don't have faith in them brother
that's what I'm saying if it turns out
to be a naughty job what do you do what
do you tell her
I mean I would just be like okay well
Becky's over here so I gotta go now
um no but seriously like
I've seen like nice jobs and I have as
well so you know so keep your fingers
crossed and maybe it's a nice job and
everything's fine and you know that's
that's probably maybe the only thing
that she ever protests you on and
everything else is going to be great in
the coming months or years or whatever
but just you know just don't take it too
seriously you've only known her for a
month keep doing what you're doing wait
wait for her to come to you and be like
hey Chris I really dig your Vibe where
do we stand you know what's going on can
I claim you deal with that later on down
the road correct she um she has been
kind of silent I haven't heard from her
for the past three to four days I'm just
leaving it open leaving it alone
considering she's in recovery mode it's
pretty painful for women yeah yeah yeah
and I know she is she's a good girl but
I'm just leaving it alone I already sent
one message I'm not gonna continue to
approach let her come to me when she's
ready cool I just hate the fact that if
I see her again and I'm gonna be less
attracted to her physically God damn and
I don't want to be in that position
because she's a cool chick but I know
it's only been a month
true that my friend love the School of
Entrepreneurship sir I signed up last
whenever you opened it last oh [__] yes
sir I go I go over it um in the evening
times when I have time I am a physician
Chiropractic physician so I don't know
if that's entrepreneur or not you know I
have my own office that I opened up the
past April but I'm just trying to get my
ideas flowing to what else I can do well
well here's some inspiration for you one
of the YouTube channels that I watch is
Dr Eric Berg and he is a chiropractic
physician by training but that's not
what he does right now now he's running
an elf business that is massively
Amplified I'll look him up Eric Berg Dr
Eric Burke yeah he's actually got really
good uh dense videos or five six minutes
long on useful topics that you want
information on and they offer Solutions
so that's yeah that's my take on it
um yeah well hope you enjoy the rest of
the course and I'll see you on one of
the zoom calls I'm sure but uh yeah let
us know how how the tailor-mades work
out for you I appreciate you sir much
love to you I hope to talk with you
again soon God bless you thanks Chris I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out